[Music]
cd projekt red has finally commented
publicly on the state that cyberpunk
2077 launched in
on last gen consoles as well as pc and
they have provided a number of updates
including
a new commitment to quality updates
about the next generation patches
as well as future fixes and updates and
dlc
let's break down what it all means i'm
lucy james joined by jake decker
hello and john luke sidekie hello didn't
expect to talk to you guys so soon
again i know for context we actually
filmed another video about the
multiplayer the alleged multiplayer
leagues uh for cyberpunk
and then this all happened so it's
definitely worth taking the time to
break all this down because
it is pretty huge of them to admit
accountability
um it's obviously been a month at this
current recording since cyberpunk
launched
let's go through everything that was in
the video and the q a that went up on
the official website
so first of all the fact that it's it's
dear gamers but let's go through the
major takeaways
let's why is there such a gap
between the pc and console versions now
they are only referring to the issues on
old gen
consoles however i would like to make
the case that
it wasn't a pretty picture on ps5 and
series x either there were a number
of crashes and other issues and pc as
someone who played the pc version
it's it's still kind of a mess uh yeah
yeah so the the main thing i mean it's
funny you bring up pc
they developed pc first like all games
are made pretty much
pc first uh and they
say that they underestimated the
difference and how hard it would be to
adjust
for ps4 and xbox one so
it looks like they basically overshot
over-promised under-delivered and that's
why
last-gen consoles doesn't look so great
yeah i don't know if anyone's seen the
digital foundry review of this game but
the reviewer pointed out that cyberpunk
27
d7 on pc is kind of future proofed at
least for the next couple years because
that there's so many
different effects that you don't
typically see in games right now
so it kind of makes sense when you're
trying to like fit all of this future
tech
into a what eight-year-old box at this
point like that that's just not gonna
work
so it's it's not that surprising but i
think the the
the final state of it was still very
surprising because
you know the witcher 3 looked fantastic
back when that came out and that was on
old tech
so yeah so martin who is one of the
co-founders of cdpr
uh called out specifically the streaming
tech
being one of the main issues with
bringing it to last gen console so if
you're unaware about streaming tech
it's not you know hey playing a game i'm
streaming it on twitch
streaming tech with regard to video game
engines it's basically
in an open world if you were to have
every single
landmark mechanic ai like all that stuff
in
nothing could run it like the the memory
would be
unfathomable to think about so a way
that video games are made it's very
clever what they do is they
anticipate where the player is what they
are looking at and they load in
what the player needs to see and what
they are interacting with
and so streaming tech is the clever way
that video games realize
you know putting in front of the player
what the player needs
and dumping the rest of it out of memory
so that can be you know it can be this
smooth experience that
some players of cyberpunk on super super
high pcs have experienced
however given bandwidth limitations on
ps4
original xbox one uh it's just not
possible and that's why
there were so many issues however they
said that test
this is the thing that i i'm really i
really want to dig into more
is that testing didn't show any of these
issues
which begs the question what kind of
environment are you testing on are you
testing on a pc running a ps4
environment
like i guess to give them the benefit of
the doubt like maybe due to covet it was
hard to communicate the issues that they
were running into while play testing it
on different consoles
that being said i feel like the state
that the game was in on ps4 and xbox one
i don't know how that doesn't get
communicated pretty quick as it turned
out our testing did not show
many of the issues you experienced when
playing the game
and they said that as they got closer to
launch significant updates
day to day the final day zero update
would be fine and that's why the console
version was so delayed
i don't understand because also i mean
johnny made a great point now notes like
are you throwing qa under the bus
yeah kind of feels a little like you're
throwing the qa team under the bus i
mean
usually when um games are buggy or
broken
like the qa team's always like no we
knew like we knew and we told them and
and i mean at the end of the day like
the higher-ups have to make that call
of you know what's uh like shippable
bug versus like non-shippable um
i also wonder if there is maybe just
some level of tunnel vision about the
whole thing of like
you know the version that we got they
were like well it looks so much better
than what we were playing
two weeks ago when we were patching it
up so to them it felt like it was
playable in comparison but like again
they have that tunnel vision where
they're
they're just so focused on the game and
then when you give it to the wider
audience who didn't have that context of
like how it was completely unplayable
and now it's
playable but it's like you know
not not really playable at least to the
standards that
you expect one thing i will say i felt a
bit weird when
martin was saying you know like i take
accountability
i i must imagine there would have been
more people of power over at the studio
um saying yeah ship it however i do
appreciate the fact that he said don't
put this on the dev team this was on us
i did very much appreciate that
and god yeah he
looked um tired you could
you could put hello darkness you could
put the sound of silence
over multiple parts of that video um
and it just it's so unfortunate that it
happened this way so
that's the why now let's move on to the
what happens
next um i'm gonna come to this part
first is because they've laid out a road
map they said there's gonna be a first
big update coming
uh the next update in 10 days uh and
then there will be a bigger and more
significant update
in the following weeks with various big
and small patches coming
here and there uh the thing that i think
everyone
is kind of it's on everyone's minds is
when is the ps5 and xbox series x patch
dropping
that looks like it's gonna be way way
later in the year did we expect that to
be pushed
so far back i didn't i figured it would
be early 2021
i don't remember if they actually said
that though that may have just been
wishful thinking on my end but yeah i
figured i figured first half of
2021 we'd see it but now it now i think
even said it would be second half
yeah so i mean they've said uh next gen
free upgrade is planned for the second
half of 2021
so they have a newfound commitment on
avoiding crunch
um a lot has been said about cd projekt
red's previous commitments to avoiding
crunch
uh we're not going to go into that too
deeply right now
um they are going to be working on
fixing and updating the game
with no obligatory over time
whether that is enforced will remains to
be seen that people don't have to wear
crunch
people shouldn't have to work crunch
like
they are actively avoiding crunch on all
future projects as a top
priority do you think we're going to be
having the conversation about
cd projekt red crunch in six months time
hard to say you know there there is that
whole article from
jason schreier where they already
previously committed to no crunch
and then they went back on that so it's
like
i'm glad they're saying it i'm glad
they're saying they're committing to it
you know have to wait and see i'm not
gonna give them the benefit of the doubt
on this one
yeah it's easy to say anything right
like especially when you've got
all the everything pointed at you
everyone's looking at you like you're
gonna say anything to get out of it
i i think like the true test will be
what you're saying lucy if
if in six months if we're talking about
this again then
i will never believe them again if they
say we're not going to
instill crunch because they've already
done it twice now every once
so it just kind of remains to be seen at
this point
i really hope they don't really hope
they don't
yeah well there are that he did mention
martin mentioned another a couple of
other
make goods in that video so there will
be free dlc planned but it's not going
to come out until after the major fixes
they will have obviously more to say in
the coming months to be expected
honestly from the free dlc standpoint
i'm not expecting
major major stuff um just yet i'm not
expecting like a heart of
hearts and stoner or blood and wine um i
mean if if we're going off of what the
witcher did they added
uh you know new outfits new costumes
that kind of stuff but also
new game plus but also they did do some
like pretty big quality of life
stuff in free dlc they like redid the
menus and stuff and
we had our own wish list of things we
wanted to see
that uh should be up in a day or two so
you can go check that out and maybe some
of that stuff will end up in the dlc
however uh if you are still
unhappy with cyberpunk and you are
looking to get a refund they did say
what is it the initiative is called help
me refund it's underway
and the first wave of reimbursements has
gone out
and with regards to getting back up on
the playstation store
again they're working on fixers and
they're working with sony
personally i don't anticipate it coming
back until after that next big patch
at least the one that's coming in 10
days or so to see like huge improvements
to the game
and honestly it's like it's not just the
relationship with the fans and the
you know over-promising and delivering
stuff it's a dissolution
of a relationship with sony that they
also need to work on rebuilding and
that's not going to be done
overnight you've got these two giant
powerhouses so
a very humbling update i think uh very
humbling for cd projekt red
like i said before it's an awful
situation
and one that's really shook
a lot of people in the video game
industry space i think
yeah i hope in six months maybe a little
bit longer this would be worked out and
people can appreciate cyberpunk 2077 for
what it is because
all said and done like i really enjoyed
the game i thought it was great and i'm
excited i've been playing a lot i plan
on playing more and i just want to get
to that point of the conversation johnny
do you have any closing thoughts
no i agree yeah i i've i'm still playing
through it right now and i'm gonna
finish it but like there's a part of me
that's like maybe i should just wait
until i can like experience the game the
way it's meant to be and
yeah i think that's just what everyone
wants at this point yes
i agree it's a huge shame i really
enjoyed my time with the two
um i'm very excited to see what these
patches can bring especially quality of
life updates
speaking of we i mentioned in the intro
but we did a video all about the quality
of life updates we'd love to see
that was originally supposed to be going
up today and then this uh
news hit happened so make sure to like
this video and subscribe to gamespot
to see that when we release it uh thanks
both of you guys for joining me thank
you all for watching
for more cyberpunk and beyond stay tuned
to gamespot
you